is that
thou sticking his finger up at me or is
he just frightening me
that's not a little angular is it no
it's not um well it could be if you want
to think about it like that
i i've had enough provocation from that
man for a lifetime
i actually um i really do have a bunch
of questions so let me just jump i'm
going for that you know
there's more time today yeah by the way
if they wrap me feel free to give me an
extra minute i really do have
i will don't worry of the uh you
remember when we were on the rooftop at
bad robot and we talked about doctor
strange you were the guy you want the
credit
for the stocks of strategy you completed
a guy well with me and jim
but it wasn't just me but i just want to
bring so this is a repeat of that moment
have you heard that people have you been
watching the mandalorian
uh no no actually i haven't i haven't i
haven't i'm trying to catch up with
films this year to vote for the baftas
and the oscars so
um i can't do a lot of the baftas
because fortunately we've been nominated
in the mauritanian so that's a little
plug there
but yeah no that's a way of saying i
haven't had much tv time and because i'm
making doctor strange
so sure yeah i've got that stored up
trees
why why what they're saying i was going
to say that there's there's a lot of
people that would like you to play
a character called grand admiral thrawn
and i'm just curious if you've heard
people
saying this because he i could see you
playing this role
grand admiral thrawn yes okay
what does he does he turn into peter
cushing or something is that
no it's a he's blue he's a very cool
character
that's a villain that would you'd be
under
like a blue makeup thing anyway i'm just
curious if i think that's
that's a straight note for me right now
i i there's no way i want to be turned
blue i could turn the air blue very very
recently but
no no seriously i i i i precious time
with my children
and uh i think sitting in a makeup show
being painted blue in the amount of time
it would take to do that and then take
it off the end of the day might
might just it's not the right time in my
life for that
completely got it real fast um as a huge
fan of your work on sherlock
do you think that chapter has been
closed or do you think there's still
more sherlock in your future
ah i don't know i'm the worst person to
ask on this because
uh you know i i never say never
obviously
um but i don't know we and i'm most
personally ask is i'm making my slate's
pretty pretty full at the moment
as is martin and all the other key
players involved so
who knows i mean i agree one day uh if
if
scripts write and and i say
the script maybe it could be a film
rather than the series who knows
um but anyway not for now sure
um i really as you know i'm a huge fan
of your work i think
i think that courier is so well done and
i think you did such a great job and one
of the things i think
is the best part of it is that it
doesn't rely on car chases or big
action to tell this story it's you know
it's about people
um talk about that aspect of the film
sure well thank you first of all for
what you said um
i'm very flattered and i you know it it
is about people you're quite right and i
think even though it's a very specific
genre and era as well that we do know as
far as the the key world stage players
of kennedy and christoph and that game
of uh
terrifying chess they play with mutually
short distraction between russia and
america
over the cuban missile crisis the
backroom
antics and and happenings and characters
such as greville and pankowski
they are known but but not so much to
our generation i think and historically
they're often overlooked
certainly this was the first i'd i'd
heard of them and for me the real
attraction to the project was
to see this every man transform into
uh someone who's adept at a spycraft and
then
from very ordinary beginnings becoming
an extraordinary human being
performing uh an act of uh selfless
and highly risky courage by trying to
rescue his friend at the end of the film
and i think you know
he came from a humble welsh background
he was dyslexic to the point of near
illiteracy
he was a gift of the gab salesman who
was always looking to um
better himself from his mother's
forceful
imprint on his childhood to to even the
tie he wears
in our film it was a note of fascination
for me all the pictures i didn't
research or saw him research rather
he was wearing the same uniform and it
is like a uniform or a costume
even for him it it and i investigate the
is the nottingham university engineering
club he never went to nottingham
university he never was a member of that
club and that
not being a member of the club is kind
of where he was at he was an outsider
but aspiring to something that he wasn't
and that that's that's obviously
quite rich terrain to become a spy and
you look at the recruitment drive
that cambridge had cambridge spies and
how
it was very much around homosexual
circles
a society of men that had to bury so
much of their life anyway in secrecy
that they were
perhaps born to carry out another duty
or
um a task with secrecy being in their
blood in their in their everyday life
and
he didn't belong to a club he was an
outsider and i think that was is often a
key element for
being a successful spy on learning how
to
be that to feel that you are outside of
any rules or belonging that you can do
things on your own and
you know having said all of that it's
for me it's
really about the relationship as well
with pankowski these two men
they shared some some appetites and some
human frailties
a lot of liquor and fine times but also
a real driver was i think the need to
secure peace in that time for their
families as well as their nations in the
world and
i think it's unthinkable how
isolating that experience must have been
that they really apart from
occasionally their handlers have only
had each other to talk to to
to relate to about the predicament
they're in can tell their families for
obvious reasons so
the the complexity that the closeness of
that i mean that's another thing i guess
that drives it away from the usual
spy thriller and yet there are all these
elements of the ticking bomb
aspect of are they going to get found
out are they going to get away with it
and just when you think oh mission
completed they kind of done it
uh he goes back to rescue his friend
this incredible selfless act now
you know this is a moment in history and
it's one guy but it i think it does
relate to now it does relate to what
we're seeing
across the board during this pandemic
but also in social movements like black
lives matter and
hashtag me too but also environmental
movements even i mean greta sitting
outside of school turning into a
a you know a global phenomenon of
becoming a spokesperson for an entire
generation
on the issue of the global climate
crisis and it's the idea that
it doesn't matter how disenfranchised or
powerless or small you may feel or how
insignificant you may feel how out of
control your world your circumstances
may feel
you can still do remarkable things and
affect real change
in people and societies in the world at
large and
they did that they averted the third
world war the nuclear crisis
that was imminent and by selfless
actions and putting themselves at risk
and
i think we've seen already huge numbers
behind the numbers of stories that are
heartbreaking and inspiring and fuel you
for hope really in humanity in their
acts of selflessness and courage and
um volunteerism and community orientated
work
in terms of people who stepped up to the
plate during the pandemic
but also like i said the other movements
as well um
protest movements political movements
and social movements that are shaping
change
but also people who are doing it without
any idea they're doing it or just doing
it
gracefully without any desire for
acknowledgement
the silent heroes of allegiance of
people who have kept this whole thing
going whether they're delivery men and
women or cleaners or
all the frontline workers clinicians
on the frontline of the health care
crisis and uh
pandemic outbreak you know it's it's
been a remarkable show of heroism
across the board and ordering people
doing extraordinary things so my point
is
i think despite it being of its era and
despite him being of his time
it has real currency in this current
moment
a hundred percent um i could ask you 50
other questions i know you have to go
but do you mind me asking a marvel
question just because
i mean we know what a dead end is going
to be but yes of course you can waste
your time asking about a question
well this is it's a two-parter i'm just
curious if you have filmed your
spider-man stuff yet
and what was your reaction looking at
that script and for dr
strange i i'm curious if you could sort
of talk about working with sam raimi
because
so many of us are so excited that he
is doing an mcu movie and i'm just if
you could sort of talk about working
with him
uh spider-man yes i know uh
sam amazing and uh you know
he's so collaborative and god he comes
with the
you know the baggage of an economy he's
just he's an incredible uh
force in in in our
well especially in this genre um but
he's so humble he's so nice he's so
appreciative
you really want to serve him and boy
when he's happy you know you've done
something right and
um he's so good at getting you there and
getting it there
you know we've it's been a very very
collaborative process this one
um you know our origin stories i guess
and obviously the beasts that were the
avengers films
to be part of were were a thrill but you
kind of just along for the ride you just
you know okay and and
you do the best with what you've already
got given to do
and second time around there's a bit
more of like so what do you want to do
and how do we you know how do we go
about solving this so
it feels very creative uh scary so
sometimes
um but it's you know we're well into it
now we've been shooting it since before
christmas
and uh you know it's a long shoot not
least because of
all the restrictions and the amazing
amount of sacrifice being made in this
bizarro world we find ourselves in but
uh it's working and i feel very safe on
set this incredible
test and tracing system they've got
already as a gold standard and um
i haven't had to turn my shirts off and
shout out to people yet um so that's
good
well the thing about sam though is that
he also does really cool camera angles
anyway you don't know he does know okay
please at least i said one more thing
yes he does that's what i'm going to say
about it sorry
hey listen um thank you so much always a
question
i'll i'll see you on the next one yeah
see you on the see on the roof of
bad robots soon i hope that would be
nice